[Musique]
votre mari est venu vous voir
je comprends pas ce qui se passe comment
je me suis retrouvé ici tu tu nies faire
tu été renversé par une voiture et
s'était cognée la tête tu sais qui fuit
tu te rappelles pas du tout je ne sais
même pas comment tu t'appelles je
m'appelle recèle serait de faire des
connaissances
j'arrive toujours pas à croire que c'est
chez nous elle appartient à la famille
depuis un moment c'est tellement
tranquille forte récession
le voisin le plus proche est à plus d'un
kilomètre seulement un kilomètre à
l'hôpital j'avoue que ça me serait très
utile que votre femme passent nous voir
ici demain que diriez vous de vos heures
ça me paraîtrait bien besoin demain à 11
heures je t'ai entendu discuter au
téléphone c'était le bureau qui appelait
ils se demandaient quand j'allais
revenir à sanya nombreux jardins
je pense que je vais aller en ville
aujourd'hui tu as besoin d'autre chose
ça qui est ça va aller j'irai juste
faire un petit tour
qui sait peut-être que ça me ravivera la
mémoire vas-y doucement comme en vue que
jennifer n'avait pas ses papiers
est ce que vous savez comment russell a
prouvé qu'il était son mari il a
présenté des photos de famille
[Musique]
j'ai dit ferreira soudure bien sûr
c'était le couple star de notre bureau
donc lui c'est russell il lui c'est qui
qu'est-ce que tu étais à mon vrai mari
c'était pas un accident
[Musique]
tout ce que j'ai toujours voulu c'est
que tu m'aimes
[Musique]